in all my life this is a true story all
my life and you play
uh you know a good friend best man
to this character well you set it up for
us because this is this is a powerful
story
yes so jen and saul have a relationship
well
jen saw they were in love with each
other they have these friends jen
uh jen and saw they get engaged they're
about to get married saul finds out he
has cancer
and they use all of the money for
chemotherapy
and whatever and they they are not gonna
have a wedding so the community
sees the story they do a gofundme they
all donate
and they do this big wedding for this
couple it's really
when did this happen 2015. yeah
it happened it's a very cool story and
we have we have a clip here which i
think you are the best man
and i think uh and in every respect you
are the best man
yeah hey thank you that appreciate that
yes it had to be said
yeah because you asked me to um
big day dude
it's gonna be perfect just like you and
jen
maybe not as perfect as my margarita but
what's this open it
find what you love and do it don't wait
dude he's on fire wasn't that amazing
we don't have the resources to actually
they just saw the clip okay okay
you and i didn't see the clip i saw the
clip earlier and you know the clip
because you're in the clip
right i know the clip i did because i
did the scene i did the movie and it it
was it's a nice sweet story it's another
side of me
it's a dramatic side and i mean there's
some fun in there in the beginning but
i mean the the whole the whole message
of the story is to enjoy
life no matter because you don't know
how long you have here you know and
and that's proven even with this year
with covet but the fact that you're here
now
appreciate those moments and just make
the most of them
and thank god you're here yeah you know
so amen
that's what i try to do you know
whatever yeah and always make sure your
jacket matches the furniture
always make sure that i tried but you
nailed it
yo literally i could disappear you only
see i'm a floating head you're a floater
there's this floating head in front of
me quite good-looking floating head
in front of me just and the rest just
disappears uh
i wondered why you called ahead and
wanted to know exactly
what color the chair was uh all my life
is a great story it's in theaters now
and it's going to be available on video
on demand
and digital december 23rd
and is there anything else i thought
there was something else i will tell you
this
conan is like come on jay i'm like yo i
want to hear it i have a project
that i'm dropping where uh i'm doing
impressions
i'm rapping doing impressions and doing
my own features
so i'm like i'm like doing the
impressions and i'm rapping as well
you know what do me a favor when that
comes out come on back because i'd love
to talk to you again let's do it you are
hilarious thank you i love talking to
you jay farrell thank you so much for
being here thank you cohen
i bow to you socially distanced yes
i give it all i spit at you